So here's a way we could define the lookup procedure.
It takes 2 inputs, the index and a keyword.
And as a reminder, I have drawn the structure of the index here.
It's a list, each element in the list in an entry.
Each entry is a list itself.
Where the first part of the list is a keyword.
The second part is a list of URLs.
So what we want to do to the fine lookup is very similar to
what we did for add to index.
We want to go through the entries in the index
to try to find one that matches the keyword.
So let’s write that again.
That's going to be a for loop, and it's going to be
exactly the same code as we had before.
So we are going to look through the elements in the index each time
we go through their loop.
The variable entry will refer to 1 of those elements.
We're going to check if the value in position zero,
which is the keyword of that entry,
matches the keyword we're looking for.
When we we're defining add to index,
what we did when we found a match was to pin the
URL to the list of URLs associated with that keyword.
What we want to do for lookup is different.
All we need to do for lookup now is return the list of URLs.
And we can find that by looking in position 1 of entry.
If we get to the end of the list without finding that keyword.
Well then we still need to return something
and the way we describe lookup, what it should return is the empty list.
That means there are no URLs that we've found so far
that contain that keyword.